alors cette semaine au cinéma les yeux
d'elsa le coup de coeur c'est la
programmation de la semaine parce que
c'est le reflet de la diversité qu'on
souhaite proposer à commencer par la
belle et la bête qu'il est inutile de
présenter le dernier disney donc ensuite
le film moonlight film américain
oscarisé sur le parcours en 3 h d'un
jeune homosexuel d'un quartier de miami
un film vraiment sensible et rayonnant
qu'on vous invite à voir en version
originale ensuite paris pinula comédie
burlesque de duos fiona gordon et bruno
romy un duo de comédiens acrobates dans
une jolie comédie douce et acidulées et
enfin s'il ne fallait retenir qu'un film
ce serait chez nous de lucas belvaux une
fable politique sur l'ascension d'un
parti d'extrême droite qui se refait une
respectabilité en allant chercher une
jeune infirmière qui est formidablement
interprété par emilie dequenne
alors tous nos horaires sont sur le site
allociné et vous pouvez trouver le
programme complet sur le site de la
ville de saint cyr l'école